Hồi nông nghiệp và mùi chương vừa có văn bản đất thúc các địa phương thu ví giác theo khổ lực,
hoặc thịt thích giác thải để bảo đảm quyền tắc nổi với ôi giám phải trả tiền theo quy định của lợt bảo vệ mùi chương.
Nhằm thuộc đẩy phân loại giám thiệu chức thải giắn xinh hoạch bảo vệ mùi chương.
Theo số liệu thống kỳ tình đến tháng 125, có năm 2018, thành phố đá banh hay quy định về khoảng lý chức thải giắn xinh hoạch.
Hến ai công tắc phân loại giác tại một ở các địa phương đang gặp nhiều khó khăn,
gió thiệu đồng bộ trong hạt tầng tư thu gâm, vẫn chuyển đặc biệt là công nghệ xu lý, nhất là với công nghệ xu lý rất thải thực phẩm.
Bộ nông nghiệp và mùi chương đình y bị bán nhân dân các tình cần khẩn chương bán hành kế hoạch,
và tổ chức chiến khải công tắc phân loại giác thải giắn xinh hoạch tư hộ ra đình.
Cái nhân trên địa bán.
Cuy định của thị hình thức và mất kinh phí hộ ra đình,
cái nhân phải chi trả cho công tắc tư gâm.
Bán chuyển và xu lý chức thải giác xinh hoạch giữa trên khối lượng hoặc thiết tích chất thải đã được phần loại,
đình giác dịch của tư gâm.
Bán chuyển, xu lý chức thải giác xinh hoạch theo quy định của pháp lợt về giá.
Cơ địa phương hình chương trình khai hoặc có kế hoạch chuyển đổi công nghệ xu lý nhằm giám tỷ lệ xu lý bằng phương pháp cho lấp,
với mục tiêu giám tỷ lệ cho lấp, chực tiếp xung xế巴 mê phần chăm 6 năm 2020.
Chúng đào yên a vụ các công nghệ tiền tiến, thân thiện với môi trường.